I'm aware of the dangers out there
and I know you're scared
but I can't hide and wait for the world
to end
so this is it
do we fight
we're really in the thick of the war
and the aliens have a stronger foothold
on Earth it's a story about a collective
surviving a moment of complete chaos for
months now we've been outnumbered
outflanked
outgunned
there's only one person who's ever made
contact
these aliens come at you even harder
they tap into your weakness they've
managed to really get into your head are
you sure you want to do this
they have evolved they are now more
vicious more aggressive
they are expanding it's still a
discovery there's still questions what
is going on and why it's happening yeah
there's right here
it's not only story about an invasion of
aliens it's about the human connection
this family is my whole world I would do
anything and everything to hold it
together and Well on a mission I just
can't see the pattern to understand how
to save Humanity
if season one was the quiet before the
storm
season two is the storm
Showtime
[Music]